foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm Christina Ellis
Ramsey personality joined today by my
co-host Ramsey personality George
Campbell we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five give us a call we'd love to chat
kicking off this hour is Ashley calling
from Nashville Tennessee hey Ashley
welcome to the show
hey how are you guys hey we're doing
great how can we help
um so my husband and I have recently
decided to be gazelle intense we have
read Total Money Makeover and
um we are on baby step two currently
let's go and so
so we finally put all of our debt
together including student loans
everything and we're sitting at about
148 thousand and my question today is I
have a small bit of mutual funds I was
gifted from a family member
um it's I think I might have an
emotional attachment to it but we're
wondering if we should sell those and
and put those towards the debt or just
leave them as is and forget about them
how much do you have in those mutual
funds
um it's only about three grand right now
you're emotionally attached to three
grand worth of mutual funds
I think I think what and we talked about
this after church the other day and I
think what is keeping me holding it in
there is because my great grandfather
worked really hard bought them a very
long time ago and I feel like I'd be
using his success to kind of help with
my mistakes
um and so I don't know we gotta flip the
script here I think he would be honored
that you're using this money to set
yourself up for a better financial
future that's how I see it
yeah fair enough how does that feel when
you hear that
um it feels good I mean I've always just
wanted to make him proud so um I think
looking at it that way is definitely
helpful for sure
I think you would be proud of that the
fact that you are going gazelle intense
and part of that is knocking out all
debt no matter what it takes you going
scorched Earth I think he would be so
proud to see you going after it
yes so cashing these out there there
might be some tax implications on the
gains that were made so that's the only
thing to consider but I would absolutely
cash these out and apply it towards your
debt
okay what's your income household
um household is 65 000 right now okay
and what kind of debts to 148
um we have in student loans 89 000.
um our total credit card debt is 19 900
and then I have a car right now that's
sitting at 39 000.
um and so we've been looking at selling
it the only problem I guess this is kind
of another question is we um owe more on
it than it's worth so we're trying to
kind of figure out how to work that out
also yeah so if you're underwater on the
car loan you're going to need to come up
with the cash to cover the difference
plus the amount to get a different car
and so do you have any money in the bank
right now
um just our emergency fund that we just
finished saving is that a thousand
dollars
yes okay so you've got a 3 000 and so
your your first step here obviously in
the debt snowball would be the credit
cards but if you sold this car we need
to come up with a difference so do you
know what the Gap is
um we owe 39 and Kelly Blue Book said
it's worth 25 right now oh gosh how is
that possible
I don't know we actually um we're
thinking about getting a second opinion
like in person at a dealership I mean
did you wreck the thing how is it worth
so much less
than you owe no we haven't it's it's
actually a great vehicle so I'm not sure
I'm not sure if it's the mileage or or
what happened but it's very intact and
clean do you have another car as well
my husband has a paid off truck it's a
97 he's had it he was like 18. awesome
okay any other debt
um just our mortgage okay
hey I'm curious you said your income 65
and you know you and your husband are in
this together what what are each of you
making
so right now I'm a teacher and I'm
making most of that he is unemployed but
gets benefits from being um
retired from the military he just had a
job interview interview today actually
and I had a job interview beginning of
the week for a second job okay good good
that's the the biggest thing I'm seeing
here on paper is we need to get this
income up because you've got a mountain
of debt comparatively to your income and
it's going to be a slog to get through
this making 65. so if we can make a
hundred or more now we're cooking with
gas we can pay this thing off in two
years how long has he been unemployed
um he got out uh this summer I think
July around July but he started school
so he was getting the bah payments and
then his veteran or his disability
um so he brought in a little over two
grand every month and I was bringing in
about 3 500. okay um is he done with
school now
he is he just graduated in December
um and so now he's been applying at
places with his degree and whatnot so
what's his degree in
criminal justice so he's looking at
police work
cool so he's so he's bringing in two
grand because of disability from the
military correct
correct and he's applying for jobs I'm
kind of wondering I know that with
police work it can take a while
sometimes to get a job to get into a
department can he do something in the
meantime while he's applying for jobs
just to bring in that extra income
um we have uh one of our
one of um and so since he's been home
during the day he will take any requests
that we get for drop-ins and walks and
things like that okay what about some
security guard work
something that's kind of related to his
field it could give him some experience
while making you know 15 20 25 bucks an
hour
yeah for sure
yeah and I mean typically that's pretty
flexible you can find it in the evening
if he needs to go on job interviews
during the day but I would bring in
something right now especially with that
mountain of debt you all can start
tackling this I mean I know it's great
to get that full-time job and that's the
goal but in the meantime I would be
hustling like crazy and you said y'all
are gazelle intent so I think that's
just part of it like let's go and one
option actually is to go to your local
credit union and just get a personal
loan to cover the gap
with you being underwater on that car
that's the only time we would say you're
technically going into debt but really
you're just lowering the balance so that
you have less of a mountain to tackle
there and then your your A1 would be
getting a beater car for five six
thousand dollars and uh you know I see
you're in the Nashville area I'm just on
auto trader sort low to high go on
Facebook Marketplace they're out there
are they pretty no they shouldn't be are
they high mileage yes uh are you gonna
brag about it to your friends no but
that's okay because we've got bigger
fish to fry than trying to impress our
friends with a vehicle right now so get
you something that will go from A to B
get a pre-purchase inspection on it so
you know it's going to be reliable and
that will speed up this process
infinitely and you may want to just
check to see what that that car would
sell for in the private Marketplace
because right now the used car industry
has been nuts whenever we were buying a
car we were seeing such a huge
difference between what was on Kelly
Blue Book and what was actually in the
different dealerships yeah quotes from
everywhere to get a full picture of what
you could get for this car and private
parties generally going to be your best
bet we're wishing you well Ashley let's
go we're excited for you to tackle baby
step two this is the Ramsay show we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Christina Ellis joined today by my good
friend George Campbell and we are taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five about this time
of year we get flooded with calls
because everyone's looking for a fresh
start with their money especially after
after a tough couple of years so if
that's you you can't wish for things to
change and expect it to happen you've
got to do something different what you
gotta have a plan and we can teach you
that plan and Financial Peace University
this is the course that will help you
rethink how you manage your money and
you'll learn step by step how to pay off
debt and build wealth guys nearly 10
million people have taken FPU followed
this plan and changed their lives it
works don't try to reinvent this and
when you intentionally follow this plan
with focused intensity this year it'll
be different you will have more peace in
your finances and in your life so start
Financial Peace University right now at
ramsesolutions.com
FPU that's
ramseysolutions.com FPU
up next we have Jim calling from Ottawa
Illinois hey Jim welcome to the show
how you doing yeah well thank you I
can't believe I finally got through we
can't believe it either Jim I tried to
stop them but they let you through
anyways
going I don't play I don't blame you
um right before Christmas I had bought
the Ramsey
um everything
the kit that was used that was marked
down like 80 all right some kind of
bundle did it have Financial Peace
University in it right right okay it yes
it had everything
how do I start with the ABCs I mean my
wife and I our living paycheck the
paycheck
we have tried we are behind in a lot of
finances right now so is your goal right
now just to kind of we got to cover the
bills and we want to get rid of some
debt is that the A1 for you that's
that's the start of it yeah okay I mean
we've got a 19 year old son so you know
I mean if something happens to us we're
in our 60s
we want to make sure that they're you
know is you know that he's not going to
basically be left with nothing
at all but our debt sure so what's your
household income
um right around 50 55 000 maybe a little
bit more okay and what's how much debt
do you have total just Consumer Debt not
the mortgage
uh right around so I would say thirty
thousand two cars
and um a couple credit cards that is not
Thirty maybe about 25. okay how much do
you owe on the cars
uh we owe 12 000 on one and we owe six
thousand on another
okay so the way you would lay these out
is using the debt snowball but before we
get to that in baby step two you got to
make sure that we are on a budget and we
are covering our four walls that's food
utilities housing and transportation you
were telling me earlier that you're
having a hard time keeping up with bills
what bills are you having a hard time
keeping up with
rename it um I mean utility bills rent
bills and is that due to not having
enough money in the bank or is it the
planning side of going wait well my
paycheck comes in here but then by the
time the bill hits it's already gone
because it went out over here yeah
that's the second part okay well I'm I
don't know if you already have every
dollar premium but we're gonna gift it
to you for one year just in case and
there's a new feature in there that I
think will really help you called
paycheck planning where you list out
your income and your expenses and it
will actually show you exactly when you
would run out of money in the budget and
it helps you figure out if I need to
move some bills around hey I need to
call the utility provider and have that
come out on the 15th instead of the 13th
for example
okay and I think that side will help you
just get the logistics of the budget
down the other piece is just paying
attention to where your money's going as
well as increasing your income so are
both of you working right now
yes we're both working part-time jobs
we've both
um I retired six months six years ago
from a 20-year job and she retired a
year and a half ago I say retired but we
didn't retire we just left those jobs
and went to part-time jobs we both put
in 20 years at our
couriers and we just seen the writing on
the wall
so I'm wondering you said rent is like a
consistent issue every month how much
are you paying right now for rent
we're only paying 7.25. luckily we have
a very understandable landlord who used
to be a member of our church okay what
about your groceries and your
discretionary spending how's that look
right now
we don't go out to eat that much we do
eat at home we both
um we both take our lunches to work
about how much do you spend a month on
groceries
[Music]
I'm gonna say
five to seven hundred
okay well one of the first things I want
you to do is figure that out for sure
because groceries that's one of the top
places that people spend and go over
budget and it's also one of the things
you have the most control over so right
now I'm doing a no spend month and it's
been a challenge but my family of four
is eating on a hundred dollars a week
it's not necessarily easy and it takes
planning but that is a spot that I'm
confident with just the two of you you
can get that down to 100 a week and with
that you're looking at another 300 a
month especially if it's the two of you
you could probably do around 50 to 100
so while we were in baby step two while
we're gazelle intense I want you to look
at cutting everything that you can and I
would start there
well we do go to Walmart we do go to
ALDI a lot
um
we've got a 19 year old who lives with
us full-time
so he likes to eat uh he is paying us
rent oh good how much I hope I mean he
pays us he's giving us 400 a month
wow I've gotta we've got to talk to him
about his insurance
okay yeah that could help with your
expenses if he's working and the other
thing I would suggest is for a season
you might need to both work full time to
get this income from 55 to 75 uh while
dialing in the budget because really
what you need right now is margin and
there's only two ways to get margin
spend less and make more and I suggest
you do both right now because I want you
guys to retire with dignity instead of
going we're retired but it sure doesn't
feel like the dream we once had of
retirement does it
no not at all it shouldn't be this
stressful it should be more fun we
should have more flexibility to do what
we want to do and you can get there I
mean this 30k this 25k in debt making
what you guys are making you can pay
this off in a year
and so in 12 months from now what kind
of habits do we have to have in our life
in order to get this debt out of our
life and that's going to free up a whole
bunch of payments isn't it
sounds like a great idea I mean that's
why we got the books we finally put the
money down and got the books because all
the time we've always used the excuse we
don't have the money to buy them we
don't have the money to buy them you
know and then finally you took the first
step which is the hardest part Jim is
just people going all right my plan
ain't working I'm ready for something
different and I love that and now we've
got to take the next step which is
actually the even harder part which is
doing the stuff putting the actions into
place and so in the baby steps we're
going to get a thousand dollars in the
bank you may already have that that's
your starter emergency fund baby step
two list all of those debts you have the
credit cards the car loans from smallest
to largest balance regardless of the
interest rate and start attacking the
little one first with all the margin you
can find with your son's rent with
cutting down the grocery bill with his
side jobs
and that will allow you to knock out
that debt free up a payment and apply it
to the next one and the next one and the
next one and so while you're doing that
you're making minimum payments on the
rest of those debts until you're
completely debt free
and I know there can be this feeling of
hey we're in retirement we don't want to
live like this we don't want to live
we're trying to work less not more right
but it's important to realize that this
is just for a season that's why we call
it gazelle intents you don't run that
pace forever this is not the rest of
your life you run that pace for a year
or two so that you can get to that spot
of Freedom so that you can enjoy
retirement without the stress without
the anxiety without the you know feeling
like you are down to the last penny
every single month we want you to be
able to breathe we want you to feel
Financial Freedom and you're not far
from that this is just a season and
you'll get through it we'll be right
back this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of Believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more our first
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Christina Ellis joined today by my good
friend George Campbell give us a call at
888-825-5225
so there's been some interesting news
today George and it involves ceilings
who knew who knew ceilings could be
interesting well I don't know if I mean
it's scary uh interesting sounds like
I'm intrigued by this uh the debt
ceiling of the U.S we have apparently
hit our credit limit Christina and
there's a lot of fears of defaulting on
this debt and the treasury has begun
what they're calling Extraordinary
Measures whoa juicy stuff oh so what's
going on
man it's interesting so it looks like we
have hit this debt ceiling and there's
debates now one side wants spending cuts
the other side doesn't want to budge
y'all it feels a little bit like the
government right now is like a drunk at
the bar who ran out of their credit card
limit and people are saying no you can't
spend anymore and they found one more
credit card in their pocket and they're
like hey everyone drinks on me oh boy
yeah so the amount of time the
department can continue taking steps to
avoid defaulting on the debt unless the
31.381 trillion limit is raised is
uncertain and so if you're wondering
what this refers to it's the maximum
amount of the US government can spend on
its existing obligations so think things
like Social Security military salaries
food stamps uh things like that and
they're voting to raise the debt ceiling
uh but the question Christina that
you're raising is the Republicans are
saying hey if you're going to raise this
thing you better cut the spending bucko
and the Democrats are saying no no hey
don't put strings attached on this let's
just raise it guys be cool be cool I'm
like this is the opposite of a zero
based budget they're basically running
on a negative budget oh yeah I'm like
can we can we go up to Washington and
and help them budget is that possible if
you ever want just a lot of a lot more
anxiety in your life you can go to
usdeckclock.org and it has running
numbers for all of the debts and uh it's
nothing like that so much red oh it's
not pretty and so this is something the
US has never done defaulting on its debt
which puts us in a really precarious
situation globally because other
countries are saying hey you guys said
you were good for the money and this is
like defaulting on your student loan
payment you can't pay
this is scary it's scary and I want to
kind of use this conversation we were
planning on doing an update on student
loans anyways we've had a lot of people
asking about forgiveness and what are
the latest updates and so I kind of want
to use this conversation to go into
student loan forgiveness okay so right
now it's supposed to go the Forgiveness
plan is supposed to go before The
Supreme Court on February 28th the White
House has said that borrowers will
resume payments 60 days after the court
cases have been resolved and if the
courts have not resolved the issue by
June 30th payments will resume 60 days
after that and I saw something really
interesting in an article by Business
Insider it said Congress did not
increase funding for the federal student
aid office in the latest spending Bill
suggesting hurdles to come with
implementation of these reforms the
administration said that the department
is disappointed with a lack of funding
and notes that it will present a
challenge
yeah so uh summary it's not looking good
it's not like if you're hoping for
student loan forgiveness it sounds like
it's going to be more uphill battles
more fighting more standstill gridlock
over uh at the White House in Congress
and I know that's stressful for a lot of
people you know I have a lot of friends
a lot of people in my life who have been
very excited for student loan
forgiveness they have breathed major
size of relief over the last year it was
going to allow them to get debt free so
I'm not really rooting one way or
another you know I think it's just
frustrating in general that there's been
so much drag in this there's been so
much political turmoil over this and we
just want to say that if you have
student loan debt right now it's really
important that you start thinking
through how you're going to pay this off
I would not count on this the US is
saying right now that it's out of money
it's running at a deficit you know and
it's not increasing the budget for
student aid so there's a lot of
complications in this I'm not saying
it's impossible I mean obviously it
could technically happen they could get
another debt extension but I wouldn't
count on it I would not count on
Washington and all of this mess going on
right now to forgive your debt I would
start working and creating a plan
yourself get control of your money don't
wait until June 30th don't wait till you
know September whenever these payments
come back to start thinking about it for
the first time and if anything right now
start paying on it because there's not
interest accruing this is the best time
to be paying off this debt you are not
accruing interest so use this as
motivation don't use this as fear use it
as motivation to get in control of your
finances to take ownership of your money
don't leave that control to people who
are literally running a negative budget
that is a scary situation but you don't
have to be scared you can follow a
budget you can carve out room for your
student loan payment and not only that
you can carve out room to get ahead
yeah this whole situation feels like
you're asking your broke friend who's
about to go through bankruptcy to cover
your tab and the dude's got no money and
so with the US defaulting on a debt it
makes it even more unlikely that they're
going to have funding for the student
loan forgiveness program and
um if the if the government does default
on this it could cause the financial
markets to tank it could hurt 401ks
other Investments uh could hurt the
overall economy the GDP of this country
and so it's definitely a a scary
situation and the best thing to do is
focus on what you can control because if
the dollar loses a little bit of its
value but I still have a bunch of money
in the bank and I don't owe anyone
anything I can still sleep better at
night right when I see something like
this instead of being like Oh gloom and
doom this is scary everything's going to
poo I'm like what can I do with my
family and my fan finances to tighten up
how can I save a little bit more
aggressively if you have debt making
sure you pay off that debt use it as
motivation to get even more gazelle
intents to press in and control what you
can control
love it all right up next we have Tommy
calling from San Diego California
hey Tommy welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me yeah thanks for
calling how can we help
so basically what I have is 115 000 in
unsecured debt and I'm current on
everything it's mainly credit cards and
sort of you know wondering whether or
not I should do a bankruptcy or should
stop paying and try to negotiate some of
that debt over the coming month
well what kind of debt do you have
what's kind of the brexit all credit
cards
it's 105 on credit cards and 10 500 in a
personal
and what's your income
so lost lost a consistent job about two
years ago and spent a bunch of money
starting a new business and then
recently just became employed again so
it's kind of unpredictable what it'll be
I do flip homes and some years I could
have an additional fifty hundred
thousand but on average I do about one
to 135 a year okay well the good news is
you you do not have to declare
bankruptcy you can get out of this mess
and it's going to take some sacrifices
and bankruptcy right now feels like a
shortcut to get rid of the pain that
you're experiencing and the debt that
you're in but it's not going to change
any of your behaviors and so what was
this 105 on credit cards what was the
majority of that spending on
so I would say the majority of it was on
a business that I have some assets
associated with I probably have if I
were to liquidate that business which is
not an option for me I probably have
about 35 000 in assets with that what's
the business that was most of it it's a
mobile radio controlled shop and track
we do events like birthday parties
corporate events
um and then we also sell products so I
have inventory for that as well how much
does that business make
um it's making me about a thousand to
fifteen hundred dollars a week profit
right now
profit so that's an extra fifty uh Plus
on top of you flipping houses
right which right now I won't be
flipping any homes for at least another
year or two until I handle this debt do
you have any homes right now that you
could sell
I don't
well I think we need to get a full-time
job then if we're not going to be
flipping houses in the meantime is it
could you get something in your field
I did and I'm now working 50 60 hours a
week but it is unpredictable what
exactly my income will be this year I'm
assuming somewhere around 80 to 100.
okay if you separated out these debts
how many separate debts are there
how many credit cards yeah
I would say there's about 20. okay so
here's what you're gonna do list those
all out from smallest to largest you're
gonna go down to a thousand dollars in
the bank make sure you can still cover
all your bills be on a budget and start
knocking away at those smallest credit
cards and the next smallest one and the
next smallest one hang on the line we're
going to send you Financial Peace
University as well as every dollar
premium to walk you through the debt
snowball to get you on that proven plan
but man it sounds like you can create
income when you want it and it also
sounds like we got to cut all the
spending cut up the cards close the
accounts it's not your friend these
companies want to keep you in debt at 20
something percent interest and I'm glad
you're done with it and you gotta go all
in on this we believe in you we'll be
right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Christina Ellis joined by George camel
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five hey if you're a
new listener I can I know it can feel
kind of overwhelming to know where to
start and you're probably ready to dive
in and we're ready to help you now if
you need help we want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
current situation so that's
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started all right up next we have
Heather joining us from Flagstaff
Arizona hey Heather welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me hey thanks
for calling how can we help
well I'm in an interesting position
where my ex-husband is dying of cancer
he just was notified last week that he
maybe has
about a month
um to live
so I'm so sorry Heather
yeah thank you
um
so he and I when we were married we both
put got term life insurance speak
directly into your phone Heather we're
having a hard time hearing you I'm sorry
is this any better that's better thank
you okay uh-huh sorry so we have uh term
life insurance policies and I am the
beneficiary of his policy because we do
have two children together and I guess
my question is when he passes should I
anticipate that I will pay for his
funeral with that money even if I'm not
permitted to
um plan it because I'm you know because
we're divorced or what I'm I guess I'm
wondering like what should I maybe
anticipate
who else would would be involved with
the planning
also around and
and may be able to help pay for that I'm
not sure do you know anything about
their financial situation
um I know that his mom and stepdad uh
are not they make a lot of money but
they spend it all and his dad has been
very good at saving and has worked
probably a couple million dollars oh wow
okay so what are your kids ages
they're six and nine
and how much is the term life insurance
it's for 750 000.
okay have you had any conversations with
family and his parents regarding the
funeral arrangements
not yet I've inquired with him at
a
um he's not doing well so his
communication his ability to communicate
is limited and so I'm just wanting to
know that I guess get your opinion like
if they come to me saying well he has
his life insurance why should we pay for
it then I kind of have an idea of how I
should respond my best
um
yeah as far as your legal obligation I
don't think you have one
um as far as the relational piece of
this equation and emotionally and the
kids being involved and the parents
being involved
um you know the funeral would probably
cost how much do you think fifteen
thousand
that's what I'm guessing yeah okay
um it could be lower depending on the
situation in your area but I would at
least start to get a picture of what
that looks like and start talking to
family about it you don't want any of
this to be a surprise and have people
angry when you're already grieving this
wild loss
so my next step would be to at least if
you can't communicate with him
communicate with the family and say hey
what what would the next steps be how do
we want to handle this
well and and for sure starting with the
conversation it's a hard conversation to
have obviously but then you know just
kind of depending on that how that
conversation goes I would settle in your
own Spirit beforehand that you may end
up paying for it and that's okay because
I know a lot of times with funerals
emotions are high I have heard of so
many funeral situations where families
get in big fights over money and they
end up not talking and it just gets
really really messy and given that you
do have the money I would just settle if
you do have to pay for it for the kids
sake for your own peace of mind I would
just not allow the the money behind the
funeral to break things down
okay and another option is just to go
hey can we all split this evenly with
the immediate family I want to use this
money to help set our the kids up for
financial success whether that's paying
for college paying off debts that we
have as I continue raising them and so I
don't think there's anything wrong with
you stating those facts
are you in a good financial situation
um mediocre I don't I have just a little
bit of debt I'm trying to pay but
um
I don't we rent it's just me and my two
kids and um I haven't had any financial
support from him for the last since
we've been divorced so okay so there
hasn't been any ongoing child support
alimony
no he hasn't been able to work
wow it's a messy situation but I mean I
and this is just we you know a lot of
times when we're in these situations
it's like if I were in your shoes I
would protect the piece in my home at
all costs I mean not at all costs you
have 750 000 but if it costs the funeral
expenses I would make sure that my peace
of mind the Peace of Mind of my children
is that they're protected as someone who
lost a father to cancer at seven years
old I know that having my mom be able to
feel peace through that situation really
helped my brother and I and I think if
there was huge turmoil among the family
and there were a lot of arguments that
would have made it 10 times harder on us
so obviously we talk about money here
money is important being strategic with
your money is important but this is also
a highly emotional situation and I would
not allow this situation to break down
the relationship with your children's
grandparents I wouldn't allow this
situation to be something that you know
causes a lot of strife and Discord and
turmoil in the family and make sure that
there is a will that is in Place signed
that's up to date go over it with the
family it's not a fun thing to do but
it's going to prevent a lot of
relational turmoil down the road and if
there's an executor of that will that
would be who would traditionally take
care of the funeral arrangements and
potentially pay for it but again there's
no there's no real heart and fact rule
against around that so this is going to
be some hard conversations and I'd be
prepared to pay for it like Christina
said and it's a small part of that life
insurance and it's one of the reasons we
tell people to get in place because it
takes the financial stress out of
something that is already so difficult
to deal with yeah and it's just a good
reminder for anyone listening to really
think through those end of life
situations I know it's not a fun
conversation to have it's kind of scary
it's kind of sticky but making sure you
have term life insurance making sure
that you have a will done so that your
family doesn't have to stress and go
through a bunch of strife if you do pass
that's just good to handle well so sorry
to hear about your situation Heather
wishing you guys the best yeah next up
we have Fernando calling from Corpus
Christi Texas
hello welcome to the show
hey guys I made it you made it get right
to the question we're up against the
clock I want to make sure we can get to
it
alrighty so my wife and I are getting
ready to purchase our first home we
found the perfect house in the price
range that we wanted it with the
interest rate that gets our payment
right where we want it the thing is we
are on a lease in a house that Anthony
July there is a house that is finishing
building in July 15 perfect timeline but
there's another one in March that will
be ready then and they can guarantee us
a 5.5 percent rate on our loan
so the thing my question is do I rush to
move and move in March or do I wait
until July to finish my leaves and
gamble what the interest rate will be
then so when you say Rush what are the
financial implications are you ready to
make that purchase in March I have I
have my emergency fund ready I am about
three or four thousand dollars short
right now but by then by March I should
have it for the down payment with my uh
yes for the down payment okay so what
percentage would that down payment be if
you had all of it
five percent oh five percent
and that's on a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage or 30.
30. okay well truthfully Fernando
putting five percent down on a 30-year
feels like you're not ready to step into
home ownership and so I would press
pause and I'm not going to be as
concerned about the interest rate if
it's going to be a percent more because
if that whole thing sways your decision
then that scares me walking into that
financial situation so I would pause I
would try to get 10 down on a 15-year
fixed rate where the payments no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay and
then you're ready to step into Home
Ownership appreciate the question well
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books thanks to the guys in the
booth thanks to you America for
listening we'll be back soon this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Christina Ellis if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm Ramsey
personality Christina Ellis joined today
by my co-host fellow Ram's Ramsay
personality a good friend George camel
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five again
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five hey if you like the show
please consider subscribing leaving a
review and sharing it with a friend it
really helps we're excited to chat this
hour ready to talk to you America
kicking off this hour we have Madison
calling from Burlington Iowa hey Madison
welcome to the show
hi hi how can we help you we're doing
great excited to chat with you
um so my husband and I have been
together for seven years and we have
made some not wonderful choices
um welcome to the club
we've all been there um yeah so my
husband travels for work and so we
bought a camper because we traveled all
over the country and that was at the
time we thought a better option than
renting at different places all over and
moving every who knows how long
um so now we have that and we went kind
of wild so that we still have like 49
000 left to pay on that
but we also have a home and we have a
baby who's almost two now and so we're
trying to sell our camper
because my husband doesn't want to
travel anymore and
so we have that we have his truck and we
have my car which I have a lease on
pretty much all of which we have regret
so when they're all on payments
yes okay
what is the total debt you all have
so without our house it's 77 000 with
and then our house we oh just a little
under a hundred a hundred thousand okay
and he said y'all don't want to travel
any more but your husband did travel for
work has that situation changed
yes so he has taken a pay cut to be home
and I have started my like a dog
grooming business out of our home so
that I can help supplement that income
um so what's your current household
income
um about 125 000. cool and what's left
on the truck loan and the car loan
exactly the truck we have about
um 10 000 and then my car
I like if I was going to trade it and
today I'd have to pay 8
765 okay now have you found out the
early buyout amount to get out of this
lease
that's what that that's what that is
okay and how much money do you guys have
in the bank
um about seven thousand okay in our
savings how much you think you could get
for the camper if you sold that
um
would like to get
45 for it okay so you're underwater by a
few grand and you've got the money in
the bank to cover the difference
okay that would probably be my A1
because you'll clear most of the debt
just from that camper and clear up that
payment
yeah and then my husband's truck
for them because he also it's a diesel
truck and he drives 45 minutes each way
for work
it's about 700 a month it just didn't
fuel for his truck so if you sold the
truck for 40 and Neo's 10 you could
clear 30 000 on that which then pays off
your your buyout for your lease
yes and still leaves you with a bunch of
money left over
right and I think he should get a car
and he needs to get
to get like a small ER truck but I'm
like I don't think that's very good on
fuel either for the moment so I'm trying
to tell him that it's not a forever car
but it's kind of a difficult
conversation it's hard to get rid of the
truck
but I mean that could really get you all
ahead
I know I can see I see the light at the
end of this tunnel and it's not far but
it's going to take some initial big
sacrifices and just some headaches of
all right we got to sell the camper
we're gonna spend our own 5 000 out of
our bank to cover the difference and
then we're gonna sell the truck for 40.
we're gonna have 30 left over after that
we're gonna buy you a reasonable
economical used car yeah and then with
the rest of the money we're gonna pay
off my car and now we're kind of at
square one where we don't have any
payments except the mortgage and we can
save up a fully funded emergency fund
and now we're off to the races
yeah I also have about 13 000 in credit
card debt oh is that part of the 77
yes okay
okay so we're just gonna debt snowball
it once this Camper's paid off just list
out all of those debts from smallest to
largest and if we're selling that truck
too that really helps speed this whole
thing up
yeah and so whatever the lowest balance
is after you sell the vehicles the
camper and the truck that we're going to
attack the smallest one with a Vengeance
and then the next one and without making
125 you guys can do this in the next few
months
yeah I have just I've kind of never been
very good at money
and I put a budget together and saw how
much I was spending and I am now like a
crazy person like wanting to spend every
dollar I have to pay off debt because
well now you know too much you you've
seen too much you're like oh gosh we can
never go back which is an awesome
feeling have you cut up the credit card
yet
uh yes and one of them was metal and so
I had my husband welder so I made him
grind off wow that's next level that
tells me that's gazelle intense so is he
on board with this whole plan is he
ready to sell the camper in the truck
and do all this to get out of debt yes
yes it was just kind of getting him a
car was kind of like the
biggest struggle well it sounds like
he's just a truck guy through and
through and he refuses to drive a sedan
yeah what about can we split the
difference can we go with a reasonable
SUV that has good fuel economy
I think so I think I'm almost you deer
hunt so he's like I don't want to throw
a deer on top of the car I'm like who
cares it's for a year that would be
quite a sight to see oh my goodness just
a deer on top of a Honda Civic well what
about a cheaper truck
so we've looked at that but cheaper
trucks I don't think they're like it's
like a GMC like older Colorado and I
don't think that would be very good on
gas
um for going back and forth I feel like
this this truck might be a future dream
and right now we get ourselves to a
great financial spot and then later on
he can get a cheap little truck just for
the deer hunting
yes that feels like the better plan
right now to base our entire financial
plan on putting a deer on a car this is
a bad lens to look at this
and if John deloney was here he would be
in support of your husband so I'm glad
Dr John is not on this call
learning from I'm like I'm not I don't
think we need a gas guzzling truck right
now well there's an order to the madness
it goes debt Freedom then deer hunting
so we just need our priorities set
straight so have him listen to this call
but you know what to do Madison and now
it's just getting about the business of
selling the camper selling the truck
paying off the debt let's get the
emergency fund let's go find the other
car this is gonna be a part-time job for
the next month but you were gonna walk
away with such freedom and peace that
you've set yourself up for we're here
for it yeah and I think as you map all
that out you can see that that light at
the end of the tunnel it's really not
that far thankfully you do have big
things to sell so I think you're going
to get there quicker than you imagine
and you can get that truck again we'll
be right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show give us
a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're talking about
your life and your money
y'all so I've been doing no spin January
with my community on social media and it
has been
learning experience experience for me is
this kind of like an Eat Pray Love
Journey for you you're learning about
yourself it kind of feels that way okay
where are you at now have you been
surviving it we've been surviving it we
have been eating on under a hundred
dollars a week on groceries we've
actually kept it pretty well under that
what is this 1997 you're throwing it
back that's amazing throw in a back
George and this is mainly due to
shopping at like Aldi and not being very
very intentional with every single
dollar being very intentional I think
I've shared this before that it felt
like last year it's so easy with
inflation and with all these things
going on for your budget to get kind of
fluffed up and I felt that way and I
kind of Hit the end of the year and was
like this isn't okay we need to tighten
back in we need to buckle down so we're
gonna do this and it's been really
interesting so I want to share a few of
the things that I've been learning so
far because I've kind of hit that point
mid-January where it's like you get over
the hump a lot of people have goals
resolutions and there's all these stats
saying that about mid-January areas when
people start going maybe I messed up
with the school maybe I shouldn't have
signed up for a no spend and I'm gonna
be really honest I've had a few of those
moments where I'm like oh my gosh the
kind of hard but at the same time
leaning into it I'm like okay I'm
learning some good things one is mindful
spending you know I thought I had pretty
good self-control and I think I do but
I've had several moments where my brain
has wanted to act like a toddler and be
like I want that now what's one of those
things oh my gosh so last weekend I was
sitting in my son's room it was kind of
a mess you know after Christmas we got
all these new toys from family and I was
struggling to figure out how to organize
it and I was like I need a new shelf and
I wow I literally a shelf a shelf that
was gonna solve all my problems I was
gonna have been excited about a shelf
that is next level it was very exciting
and I sat there like literally going
through my mind trying to justify how it
was essential and could qualify for the
no spin challenge wow but I did hold off
and I was like okay I'm gonna hold off
the next day I still woke up thinking
like I need that shelf but I was like
I've committed to a community of people
that I am not going to spend on
non-essential items this month and so I
did not buy it and then fast forward a
few days and I realized I don't actually
need the Shelf George you don't need
more storage I actually need to
declutter less crap right I need less
crap so it's interesting how we often
will just jump to spending and buying
something to solve a problem when in
reality that's really not fixing the
problem and so just challenging myself
to go okay like what is the real issue
here if I don't just try to solve my
problem immediately with buying
something
like how many garages I pass in my
neighborhood and they're just filled to
the brim with boxes there are no cars in
the garage they can't fit the nice cars
on payments are in the driveway because
there's too much crap in the garage that
is how we have become broke America
exactly wow all right food is another
big one and I've seen some users uh jump
in with their comments Chris Marlow said
48 bucks was our gross grocery bill this
week for a family of four during no
spend January that's impressive
well who've committed to this challenge
at the beginning of the year and they
are winning Bill James wrote you and
George inspired my wife and I on the
podcast with no spend month we were
fluffed up to thirteen hundred dollars a
month barely eating out on Sunday I went
to Aldi with our list I used a
calculator as I walked around I love
that I initially went in trying to beat
a hundred dollars and walked away with a
cart full and a week's worth of
groceries for 75
thank you and your team for all you do I
love that that's incredible it is so
cool to see people challenging
themselves and people who thought you
know I'm decent with my grocery budget I
don't spend anything crazy but then when
they get really Mindful and they really
create a meal plan and they really
create a list when they go into the
store seeing just how much they can save
and how quickly they can get ahead oh
yeah can I read the comment from the
skeptic yeah I'm gonna read it how I
think they wrote it I'm sorry no don't
tell the rest of us to spend unless and
be smarter we shouldn't have to as you
say cut it back and Shop sales to
survive
does that sound accurate I think that's
how they said it that was incredible
George thank you James
it just has that that attitude of I
don't want to change I don't want to
sacrifice I'm happy being mediocre and
anything you're doing to better yourself
is offensive to me I mean I kind of felt
that way that's today's society
Christina but at the same time like we
can't control the system like of course
we're frustrated that like grocery
prices have gone up I would love for it
to be cheaper that would be great but I
can't control that so I'm gonna think
through like what can I control what can
I do for me and my family to make
progress and it's like if you have that
attitude that you're a victim that you
know you're just going to complain about
the situation and not do anything like
you're never gonna win absolutely
Christina you know I got a lot of flack
for my my reel I posted saying it's
cheaper to eat at home than to eat out
and everyone's like are you insane have
you been to the group this guy hasn't
been to the grocery store since 1998.
and so I just want to give you guys the
middle ground here because I actually
live this stuff out I went to Sam's Club
and Costco these wholesale clubs and I'm
a soup guy I love a good soup and so
Sam's Club has this you know
Mediterranean style lentil soup very on
brand for me as someone who is
Mediterranean and it's eight dollars for
a two pack of these giant containers
so if you do the math it's less than two
dollars a serving that's amazing so you
can feed a family of four for eight
dollars and it doesn't require a
thousand dishes and your time is so
valuable that you can't listen you just
heat it up in the microwave or on the
stove top and dinner's ready in five
minutes there's no excuse right and it's
healthy and it's healthy like that's a
win all the way around so it can be done
and then finally the last thing that's
really stuck out in my head is I learned
recently about this concept of third
spaces so our first space is our home
our second space is our work and our
third space is kind of like where we go
to hang out and have fun and it's so
easy nowadays to make that third space
the mall TJ Maxx or some sort of store
Target Target that definitely is the top
of the list yeah you hitting me right in
the heart George and it's like that if
you surround yourself in those moments
with things that want that make you want
to spend money you're gonna be more
likely to bust your budget so thinking
through what are third spaces that don't
require you to spend money I know a lot
of people think that this is like a
relic of the past but the public library
y'all it is amazing like check out your
local public library they have free
books that you can rent a lot of times I
posted this on social media and a lot of
people were sharing that their libraries
will let you rent toys that they'll like
Let You Rent Lawn Equipment which is
just Bonkers and amazing to me
um also you know parts some playgrounds
a lot of cities have amazing free parks
they're always building these new
Incredible parks where actually this
month going on a tour of the parks
around Nashville wow that is like the
nerdiest hippest thing I've heard in a
while I love it I mean in your church
like if you have a church Community you
know get involved there and then be
creative with your friend group you know
consider rotating houses doing potlucks
or dessert nights and creating fun free
spaces where you can hang out and I mean
this one has been a big challenge to me
because this is going to sound terrible
I'm kind of embarrassed to admit this
but you know we moved last year and on
Friday nights we've got two little kids
we're trying to keep them happy you know
keep them entertained we're exhausted on
Friday night and we started using TJ
Maxx it's our third space wow TJ Maxx or
Target because it's got a great kids
section the kids will be entertained we
can kind of decompress and raise up
raise up those Max and Easters Christina
respect I think I can do better than
that that's fun yeah so it's been good
it's been very humbling it's been
humbling and awesome awesome and it's
great to do it in community and it's
also a good reminder of when you're
making these big Financial changes when
you're going through challenges with
your finances when you're getting
gazelle intents to get in community with
it like honestly there's been several
moments where I've tried to justify
things in my head and I'm like no I'm
not going to a lot of my friends I'm not
going to lie to my Instagram Instagram
Community who is doing this challenge
with me like I feel accountable and so
it's just so important too with FPU if
you're in Financial Peace University if
you are on baby step two if you're
trying to get gazelle intense surround
yourself with people who have similar
goals who have similar values community
that accountability factor is so huge I
love it well hey continue on the journey
with us with this no spend month we'd
love to hear uh how you're doing that
you can send an email to ask
ramseysolutions.com and put no spend
month in the subject line we'd love to
hear creative ways you are saving that
cash let's go we'll be right back this
is the Ramsay show oh
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
visit blinds.com to save up to 45 off
everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Christina Ellis joined today by my
friend George camel we are taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five next up we have Luke
calling from Toms River New Jersey hey
Luke welcome to the show
how you guys doing we're doing well how
about you
good
um so I have about maybe 19 000 in that
um being probably about like 4 000 on my
car and then just a little under 15 000
in student loans
um I just learned that I don't I don't
have any interest on my student loans
until August
so
um I make about 2 300
um a month and I just want to be able to
pay that off before August so I don't
have the interest occur
and I'm able to make my car payments and
car insurance payments as well but I
want to be able to invest and save at
the same time but should I be able
should I do that or should I be spending
more on my student loans so you don't
you're not paying interest on the
student loans because you just graduated
recently or because of the student loan
forgiveness proposal
um there is a Care Act I guess they have
on the student loans uh the payments are
potential
yes when did you graduate
um I just graduated trade school in
October okay
how old are you
24. okay
cool well it's an awesome goal and I'm
glad you're asking this question and you
should absolutely pause all investing
until you've got this debt out of your
life and you have fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
do you have any money in the bank right
now
yeah I have about six thousand awesome
so what I planned on doing was doing
1500 towards my student loans a month uh
up until that August until that last
month and then whatever remaining
balance I had I was gonna
pay it off what's your car payment
uh uh about like 270 a month and with
car insurance it's about 165 so about 4
30 4 40
um a month we've been between those two
so what if you paid off that car loan
today and you freed up 270 bucks to
start throwing extra onto the student
loan payments
uh
yeah
um let me rephrase that about that pay
off the car today and use the 270 to
start paying off your student loans
okay so if you're following the baby
steps which is the same way I got out of
forty thousand dollars worth of debt you
would go down to a thousand dollars in
emergency fund savings temporarily and
use all extra money to pay off Consumer
Debt aggressively
okay so that's the plan as long as you
can make your other bills with your
future cash flow that would be the plan
Luke what's your hesitation
um
I don't know just kind of planning it
out and making sure it's going in the
right spot
okay
um I guess since I I already know my
interest on my car I have that stuff
um
my I just want to be able to have that
remaining be able to have that remaining
balance where I can pay it off in the
last month for my student loans you're
going to make more progress if you use
all the money you have except for that
thousand dollars to pay off the debt
today because you're freeing up a
payment
and so that 270 working for you instead
of against you with interest by the way
is going to help you get rid of those
student loans by August can you do any
extra side work as well because it
sounds like right now you're are you
working full-time
yeah I'm working full-time but I do have
a job that I've worked in the past this
is my first full-time job
um that does happen in the spring and
summer that I could do
um you know once once a week with them
on the weekends
well I mean I'd probably be making about
like 200 a day with that and that would
really be it wow that would speed up
that debt snowball process for sure
yes definitely Luke I kind of feel like
you're at a you're at a crossroad right
you you obviously are calling into the
show which is amazing and you've got
this idea to pay off the debt you've got
the idea to pay off the student loan and
on the other hand it's easy to kind of
slack because it's not super pressing
right now I don't know that you've had
like a complete I've had it moment that
a lot of people have had when they have
a hundred thousand dollars in debt but I
would encourage you like this call if
you walk out these steps if you pay off
this debt if you start investing and
following the baby steps you're young
you have the potential to be a baby
steps millionaire you know in 10 to 20
years like you have the chance right now
to do this the right way but it's a
little tricky because there are so many
you know different Tick Tock influencers
around there there's so many different
people who are going to tell you like
the student loan debt's not bad that you
can just kind of stretch it out wait for
forgiveness all these different things
but I hope that you're willing to say In
This Moment like I've had it even if
it's not a huge amount of debt even if
you've just graduated dead but like make
the decision to really fight now because
it's like if you do that you will be so
much further ahead than so many adults
who wait to pay off their debt who wait
to start investing like you're gonna get
there but do it the right way even if it
feels slow at the moment even if you
don't get to do the flashing investing
right now like you will get there
so let me show you what this looks like
on paper you've got six grand in the
bank you owe four on the car that leaves
you with two if you pay off the car
today we're gonna throw one of those two
at the student loans now our student
loans are down to 14. you want to pay
them off by August great you got 14 000
and you want to pay it off in seven
months that's 2K a month so now we need
to figure out how can we create two
thousand dollars worth of margin to
throw out the student loans to pay it
off by August it's that simple and it's
that hard and so your goal now is to get
the income up and follow these steps so
that you can be completely debt free by
August your next goal by August is to
start up that emergency fund of three to
six months so by the end of the year
dude you'll be in a completely different
place financially
oh yeah I know it's just I knew I I
could do this I just didn't know where
to really start and you know now you
said like just get me a car payment down
and then you can focus on student loans
because I just don't want interest
nobody wants interest well you're going
to feel the progress immediately if you
follow it this way and remember we're
not doing any investing because every
single ounce and Penny of margin needs
to be focused on that debt you got this
man thanks for the call hang on the line
Luke we're gonna get you in Financial
Peace University Austin's gonna pick up
we're going to gift that to you to help
you walk through these steps one by one
doing it the right way all right next up
we have Ethan calling from Salt Lake
City Utah hey Ethan welcome to the show
hey guys appreciate it yeah thanks
well I'm on baby steps four five and six
and I got a retirement question
um I put into a Roth 401k at my work
um but they limit me to 10 or 10 per
year because of my income and that's I'm
not able to quite reach the Roth cap or
the 401K Ross cap so on this side I've
got Ross set up so that me and my wife
can put into them each year but my
question is once I Max those out
um what is the next best option and my
company also offered this year this
thing called the super Ross but it looks
like it's really complicated and has
super concerning tax stuff so there's
two versions of the super Roth one is
basically a scam involving index
universal life insurance and the other
one is more of a mega backdoor Roth is
what it's traditionally called which is
after tax contributions to the 401K yeah
that's that one oh yeah I researched it
to make sure because when I seen that in
his whole life I'm like whoa whoa no way
okay cool so you're saying they they cap
you at 10 you don't even hit the Roth
401k limit
not quite so I came close last year
within a few thousand dollars but I I
mean I don't know what it'll be this
year I'm hoping I'll still get to the
max here so what is your income
around 180
I've never heard where they won't even
let you max out your 401K
well it's because of uh highly con
compensated employees if some if some
loophole that between Labor Department
IRS that they cap individuals that make
over 130 to
I don't know it don't make sense to me
but that I I called up several different
ladders and made sure everything on the
way around it without going to a
different 401k plan which they don't
offer so your other options would then
be uh do you guys make too much for the
Roth IRA contributions
um
I'm not sure what you mean like outside
my work is that I mean there are income
limits for the Roth IRA outside of work
so look into that to see if you guys hit
that cap on the AGI and if you can't
contribute to the Roth IRA you could do
what's called a backdoor Roth where you
contribute to a traditional IRA and then
you convert it into Roth so I would be
connecting with a smartvester pro
ramseysolutions.com for a high earner
you want to know all of the strategies
you can use to build wealth and there
are a ton out there that we don't have
time for here so connect with a smart
Master Pro and they can help navigate
for your situation
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show hey give
us a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're taking your
calls on your life your money your
mental health your career whatever is on
your mind today we're here for you hey
if that Peloton bike you got in 2020 is
still sitting unused in your garage you
know the difference between goals and
resolutions and that is a personal
attack on me because that was us and we
sold it because we were not using it
goals are things you actually set out to
achieve and resolutions are the things
you say you know that'd be nice if I
could uh but you know it ain't gonna
happen so if you've got goals to improve
your money your career your
relationships this year don't let them
hang out in your garage for three years
okay maybe not the best metaphor you
know what I mean get the Practical
proven plan to crush the debt and build
wealth with Dave Ramsey's best-selling
book The Total Money Makeover and learn
the seven baby steps to guide you along
your money Journey if every day feels
like Monday for you maybe it's time to
find your true talents or a new career
and you can do that with Ken Coleman's
get clear career assessment to learn
what you were created to do and what
careers fit you best and some of us are
still recovering from the holidays and
if you're looking to deepen your
relationships with your spouse your kids
your friends your family be sure to pick
up his new questions for humans decks
from our friend Dr John deloney and
never mind the Peloton get some books
and tools that will actually take your
goals Way Beyond the dusty garage you
can check out all those books and order
them today at ramseysolutions.com store
and it's such a good time for it because
we are in that time of the month where
we start losing a little bit of Steam on
those goals and resolutions and I think
it's one of those times to kind of check
yourself and go you know what I started
this year really wanting this goal I
really wanted to do this I felt
motivated and it's kind of waning but
literally at any moment you can say
here's a moment where I'm gonna get
motivated again I'm gonna dive in so you
know Let it Be Your wake-up call if
you're starting to lose some steam you
know dive back in those Christina
shopping for the workout clothes is
really fun doing the workout way less
fun and it feels that way with with your
money too the idea of wow getting on a
budget and saving that sounds awesome
doing it's hard and so these books will
inspire you to Greatness I know Total
Money Makeover a little fire under me
when I read it a decade ago and I know
it it continues to do the same for
thousands of you out there so good all
right let's go back to the phones next
up we have will calling from Memphis
Tennessee hey well welcome to the show
how are y'all doing we're doing well how
can we help
uh well my father died in 2021 and we're
getting around to settle in his estate
deals now and we sold a minority
interest in the company he had and
didn't have a will and so when that
money comes down will be divided by four
and each kid could roughly be sitting at
about 300 000 in an inheritance and I
just want to get advice on how not to
squander the opportunity that I do have
well we're so sorry for what you're
going through that's a lot to process
how old are you
19. wow how old was your dad
uh 66 I believe oh man
how's the family doing right now
uh well last year was a rough one but
it's getting better
yeah where are you at financially
uh I'm doing pretty good uh no debt uh
19 mine comes anywhere between 35 and 40
a year
what do you do right now
well my father owned a couple of the
Sonic Drive-Ins and I was working there
trying to go into that role and now I've
lost a passion for that and I'm trying
to pursue real estate as my career do
you want to be a real estate agent yes
okay so right now I mean you've had some
time to think about this money what is
kind of your dream and vision with this
money
uh well I know I can get a head start on
investing in the whole deal and
I mean I know I can take a little bit of
it and enjoy it obviously but because
that's what he would want me to do but
it's just
I don't know I I've never been good at
managing money for the most part and
this is a large sum of money well that
self-awareness is so important and I'm
glad you have that and the good news is
we can move slow we don't have to make
any rash decisions in the next few
months when is this money actually going
to be sitting in that account
we're sitting like a month away okay
well I would let it sit there until you
know what to do next luckily you don't
have any debt do you have any money in
the bank currently in savings
I've got about 5 000 in savings right
now okay awesome so I would look at
fully funding your emergency fund that
5000 is a great start it may look more
like ten thousand for you for three to
six months of expenses are you renting
right now are you a homeowner
uh I'm still with my mom doing some
online school Okay cool so we're not in
a spot where we're needing to go
purchase a home do you have a reliable
car
uh somewhat yeah okay so maybe we
allocate a small portion of that to
upgrade to a used car that we pay for
with cash that is I'm going to say less
than less than fifteen thousand in your
position with your income because we
don't want too much of your life tied up
in that depreciating asset
okay and beyond that you want to start
building what we call the Dream Team and
so when you have a large sum of money
now we have to look into insurance so
you need a good insurance agent you're
going to need a good investing investing
professional uh you might need to go to
state planning attorney
and you might need a tax attorney
and when it comes time to buy a house
you're going to want a great real estate
agent and so with all those together you
can find a lot of those at
ramsaysolutions.com and click on Ramsay
recommends to start assembling that team
but they will help with the heart of a
teacher guide you through this process
to help you make the most of this money
and protect it too right you want to
protect this wealth that was so
generously left to you through your
dad's Legacy yeah well we're going to
get you into Financial Peace University
as well you mentioned that you're not
good with money but the fact that you
don't have any debt and you've got five
thousand dollars in the bank I actually
think you're better at money than you
realize and going into this new season
of your life having this large chunk of
money we want you to learn how to build
wealth with this money we want to see
you take this money that your dad left
you and honor his legacy you know
Building Wealth and really getting you
to an amazing financial situation so
hang on the line Austin's gonna pick up
I really believe that this is going to
be something that you can invest well
you'll Steward it well the fact that
you're even calling today just gives me
great hope for what you're going to do
with it sorry about your loss but we are
we are with you our hearts are with you
will all right next up we have Lily
calling from Raleigh North Carolina hey
Lily welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me yeah thanks
for calling how can we help
um so we just started the baby steps and
we're on baby step number two
um
and I start student teaching in August
I'm currently a stay-at-home mom
um so I was just curious how do I go
about paying off my debt as well as
being able to afford child care to get
my degree
oh so what is your household income
right now
um
it's we take home about 32
000 but we don't
um have to pay rent because we live on a
military base oh great I breathe a heavy
style a little bit because of child care
man it's it's a lot I was talking to I
mean it's like a mortgage payment yeah I
was just talking to remember yesterday
and she was touring a daycare and it was
literally the cost of some people's
mortgage so do you know what child care
would cost
thousand five hundred and six thousand
dollars
um that's for the whole time I'm student
teaching okay and will you have any
income while you're student teaching
I will not be able to make anything no
okay and what about your husband
um yes he will be working as it'll be
about 32 000 for the year is he working
full-time
yes is he able to do more work on the
side
I'm not sure he's active duty military
so
um
okay well try
with the student teaching is this
something you could take a pause on
while we pay off the debt
um
School says I to complete it within one
year okay how much is the debt total
38 000.
all right I'm gonna try to sell
everything we can if there's a car that
can be sold because we're not using it
get rid of that but we need to find some
way to bring in some income to cover
these bills and even if you work odd
hours where it's like you know whenever
your home your husband's home sleeping
with a kid and you can go out and take a
night job I know it's not easy and I
know that that's not going to be fun but
if it's just for a season I know you can
power through that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books thanks for listening America
thanks to the guys and the booth we'll
be back soon
[Music]
foreign
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Christina Ellis Ramsey
personality joined today by my friend
and fellow Ramsey personality George
Campbell we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five kicking off this hour we have John
and Paducah Kentucky hey John welcome to
the show
hey
hey how can we help
I have some questions about the
Financial Peace University
I'm really interested in it and my wife
is very skeptical
tell us about her skepticism
well you know there's so many online
influencers that she just thinks she
just thinks it's all a scam oh
what what kind of scam are we running
here John I'm curious well how does she
Define scale
I don't know I'm really interested in
the Financial Peace University I was
wondering if I could hear a few more
things about it well I'll tell you this
uh most scams out there for online
courses all involve you making a lot of
money really fast get rich quick right
right we promise get rich really slow
so it's kind of like the opposite of a
scam because it actually involves you
doing hard work and us doing uh very
little other than telling you that you
can do it and showing you the path and
so this is simply uh this online course
was something Dave Ramsey has been doing
for 30 years now 10 million people have
gone through Financial Peace University
they've changed their family tree by
getting out of debt and Building Wealth
and none of it involved some sneaky
investment thing it was just hey you
paid to go through a course one time and
then we gave you the tools to go do it
I want to hear more and this may just be
my own curiosity but I want to hear more
about the scams that she's running into
so is it I mean obviously there might be
she hasn't she hasn't ran into any scams
she just thinks I'm crazy for listening
to things I hear online you know yeah
most of the stuff we put out there is
free and so I don't know many scammers
they're like here's here's all our cards
on the table and if you want to go
through this course you can do that
so I mean I'm happy to gift it to you I
don't know if you were calling in hoping
to do that but hey you know I I'm happy
to gift it to you and your wife for free
so it involves zero dollars and we're
not going to ask you for money later
there's no love offering at the end of
the nine weeks we just want to help
people build wealth and get out of debt
no I wasn't hoping for that I was truly
just curious she was curious and I'm
curious myself you know I just wanted to
know more about it the simplest way is
there's nine video lessons in there and
you can join a local class that are in
your community uh in the Kentucky area
you can find one online or you can go
through it at home on your own terms on
your own time and so you can watch each
lesson there's fill in the blanks
there's budgeting as a part of that
through every dollar our budgeting tool
that's included in that and each lesson
just covers a different topic and so we
start with kind of the framework we go
into getting out of debt having Savings
in the bank for emergencies investing
for the future we talk about insurance
we talk about generosity and so there's
a lot of basic principles in there this
is common sense stuff that you know God
and Grandma talk about and so there's
nothing in here that's going to like
blow your mind of like I didn't think
about it
it's the newest coolest Trend ever it's
the least trendy thing out there
well and John I would encourage you to
hop on Facebook we have a really active
baby steps community and you can see a
lot of people in there who are winning
who've done the steps who are the best
cheerleaders because they have literally
just committed to the process walked it
out and they're super successful in
their finances now and that's the
beautiful thing about Dave having 30
years of experience is that we you have
so many people who sell it for us now
because it's changed their lives I mean
the proof is in the pudding and I can't
believe I just said that that makes me
sound like I'm a hundred
but the proof is all these people who
are winning with money so I encourage
you to have her get on there and check
it out because it's like they'll tell
you they'll tell you why they won
they'll tell you how they were
successful and just be really excited
about it
thanks for calling yeah most games are
easy for the person you know they'd say
hey just give me some money I'll turn it
into I'll 10x your money by tomorrow our
plan is hey uh here's how to get out of
debt now you have to go sell the car and
work three jobs so that's like the worst
scam ever that we're running over here
and uh John since it's free I'll give
you your money back if it doesn't work
out for you how's that I feel like it
was a really good deal
all right up next we have Tammy calling
from Columbus Ohio hey Tammy welcome to
the show
thank you guys so much for taking my
call I love listening to you too oh
thanks for calling
how can we help today we're trying to
help our daughter decide if she should
start her PhD in the fall next fall or
get into the workforce with her Masters
and we've had several phone calls and
she's met with her advisor so we just I
just wanted to see what you guys thought
so tell us a little bit more so so she's
got her Masters right now what did she
study
so she uh got engineering so she has her
um Bachelor's in mechanical engineering
she'll graduate in the fall in the
spring the spring with her Masters in
industrial systems engineering and what
does she want to do
well he wants to design Prosthetics and
heart valves and cool um and to say in
that area and he said she has no student
loans
we have no student loan debt no fine we
did not have a few kids debt-free
um but we'll have one finishing next
year she'll be a senior in college and
my other one is in grad school but
um and so no student learned that no
doubt at all for for them so so tell us
what to do what's what are the career
prospects look like between her going
out right now with her's master's degree
and getting a job versus her getting a
PhD
so
um when she and I had talked she had
said you know she's been at school for
you know six years and and she does
enjoy what she's doing in grad school
but she said well I want to start
working so I can start making money and
putting in towards retirement and
so we had talked about that because the
PHD will be four years he met with her
advisor and he had told her
um and she likes him and she had told
him he had told her if you if you get
your PhD you know you kind of will be
the top of your field not just the top
of the company but in the long run
you'll make much more money in being
able to call it your own shots so her
PhD is fully funded plus a stipend to
live on does she want to do a PhD
well and she she really does enjoy what
she's doing in mechanical engineering
but she also
thinks that there are also wonderful
opportunities for her but she's afraid
of the money that she's going to miss
out on if she doesn't go into the
workforce is there an opportunity to do
this PhD later can she get into the
workforce and feel it out figure out
what she wants to do and then an
employer could fund that later if that
helps her get to where she wants to go
and just with the opportunity of it
being completely funded and the stipend
that was her concern was she may not get
this opportunity again
well it sounds like some of that
decision is out of fear like some fomo
there yeah like you know missing out on
the money in the future but it sounds
like she wants to go into the workforce
now that that is her desire and the
reason to get a PhD is more fear-based
so if I'm in your shoes I'm going into
the workforce I'm getting my feet wet
I'm making sure that you know I love
that form of engineering and just go in
front of it what if she gets the PHD and
then gets into the workforce and goes oh
gosh this is ain't it right it's just
worries me more specialized in a field
that she doesn't actually love so I mean
I think that you know the route but it's
still kind of hard because of the fomo
we'll be right back this is the Ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show give us
a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five our question of the
day comes from Cheyenne in Illinois I'm
currently a nurse with a monthly
take-home pay of
3734 after monthly expenses I have about
thirteen hundred dollars left I have
twenty three thousand dollars in debt
plus my car plus my mortgage well from
her car so she got 23k on the car and
then she has a mortgage aside from that
there we go I'm enrolled in a master's
program and trying not to take on any
further debt during my final two terms
of school I'm on a tuition payment plan
for the current six-month term and
paying 986 dollars a month for the first
four months with no payments due during
the last two months of the term should I
consider the tuition as debt and save
toward it during those two months when
no money is due or should I place that
extra money on my car payment it's those
two months of that term that I will have
extra money until I have to make those
payments for the next term wow this is
like one of those math riddles in school
where you have to reread it like 17
times but here's what I gather from her
scenario
so she's got 23k on the car and then she
has a mortgage we're going to put the
mortgage aside right now the goal is to
cash flow School Cheyenne and you've got
1300 left every month to cash flow this
and you need 986 which is great and so
your goal I wouldn't put anything
towards the car until we have college
fully paid for we don't know what the
future holds so let's just focus on
paying for school avoiding debt once we
graduate from the program we can start
attacking that car loan and if you
really hate it you want to get out of
this you could sell the car and get
something cheaper for now and upgrade
later so that's an option for you but
what I'm saying is she needs about four
grand for the first term and four grand
for the second term well and she's got
1300 a month left so she's actually
making more than the 986 she needs a
month so she'll make she'll make 15
grand she'll have 15 grand extra over 12
months and she only needs eight extra so
you've got the money and so if you want
to keep saving well 15 minus eight
that's going to leave you with a big
chunk of money you can start throwing at
the car once you graduate so I would
just focus on one thing at a time and
make sure that we can cash flow that
because we don't know what if the second
term is more expensive what if we didn't
account for extra fees or books or who
knows what and so I would focus on that
well and that's tricky because it does
get a lot of people when they're looking
at paying for college tuition is a lot
but there's a lot of other expenses that
can pop up and surprise people or they
potentially take a bit longer so we do
really want you to focus on making sure
you go out of school debt free and don't
take on more debt love it thanks for the
question Cheyenne did we Solve the
Riddle George I think we solved it I
think we would have got a gold star if
we were in school ah I hope all right
next up we have Lance calling from
Syracuse New York hey Lance welcome to
the show
hi big fan
um my question is I just bought a house
approximately three months ago and I
got a really good deal on it I got it
for 65 000 and um it needs a lot of work
though
um I ended up taking out a 25 000 loan
to pay for the house it was in
pre-foreclosure so I couldn't uh go
through traditional mortgage
um I took out another loan to do some
upgrades on it and that's approximately
25 000 as well and it has to be livable
for me to refinance it into a
traditional mortgage now my thought is
if I can swing it
um to
go ahead and just pay off the two
personal loans at nine percent interest
uh and and just pay that off and be debt
free in five years if I go to a mortgage
which is approximately seven percent
um that I'm in debt for the next 15
years I'm just wondering which one which
path I should try and uh well you don't
have to be in debt for 15 years you
could pay that thing often too if you
wanted
right true yeah so we're just talking
about you're gonna you would save the
two percent obviously there's going to
be costs with the refinance so you'd
have to figure out are you even going to
Roi based on how quickly you're going to
pay these off
okay you know if you're gonna pay 4 000
extra in interest on those nine percent
loans but the the refinance is going to
cost you five thousand uh then it may
not be worth refinancing you may just
want to get rid of these loans instead
of switching to the traditional what's
your income right now
uh my
20. okay and then why would this take
five years if you're making 120
um because of all the uh Renovations
like literally this house needs a full
gut job all new water lines drainage I
just put in real Sonic Windows
um it's and I'm trying to cash flow as
much as I can did you put 40 000 down
yes okay so you put 40 down which left
you with a 25 000 deficit you got one
loan there to cover that and then you
got another 25 000 loan for the repairs
so we're 50 000 in debt total
yes so the the 25 000 loan for upgrades
how close does that get you to it
technically being livable
it actually gets me very close uh I've
been working with the buying this house
for the past year and three months uh
before I finally closed on it and uh in
that time I ended up accumulating
windows and and a bunch of different um
construction supplies and I'm able to do
most of the work myself
um so it gets me very close to livable
when I spoke to the bank about
refinancing if they said it doesn't have
to be finished drywall or or painted or
trimmed even
um it just needs to be livable which
means you know water line you know
running water
um and uh sewage as well and electric
and are you all living there I will be
no no we're actually living with the um
laws right now and and I give a shout
out to them because they have been a
huge help in this process if it wasn't
for them we my wife and I would have
never been able to do this that's
awesome so how much more money is it
going to take to get this place to where
you want it because you're 50k in debt
now that'll get it to a okay spot how
much more to get it to where you want it
to go
I
I've seen approximately 15.
okay so the goal now is to not go into
debt any further on this thing in cash
flow that 15 when the time comes
yes yes that's what I'm working on so I
would use that you you already took the
25k loan to Renault I would get it
livable talk with your mortgage lender
and have them run out both scenarios of
hey if I'm gonna pay this off in this
amount of time is it worth going to the
conventional loan at a lower interest
rate based on the cost of refinancing
and they can run those numbers out and
show you how long it would take to Roi
on that
okay and then cash flow the other 15
once it's livable let's pay down this
debt and then let's cash flow the rest
and that should free up some payments in
order to do that but this is going to be
a little bit of a journey
for sure kind of an adventure and it's
it's good you have somewhere safe to
live now because the whole process of
renovating can be quite I know you get a
deal and you're like I got a killer deal
and you're like this I hope this deal
was worth the headache goodness gracious
this is a year-long project that always
took more time and more money than I
wanted it to but I hope it I hope it
turns out beautifully for you Lance
that's awesome
all right we uh one week ago we did our
Building Wealth livestream event right
here at the headquarters we live
streamed it to hundreds of thousands of
you watching and many of you are still
wondering Building Wealth in this
economy is it really possible well we
keep hearing that question we get the
confusion there's so much noise right
now about inflation and layoffs and the
debt ceiling and Rising interest rates
and you're freaking out and you need
some answers and that's why we're coming
to a city near you with our Building
Wealth live event Dave Ramsey and our
entire team of Ramsay personalities will
be doing a Building Wealth live spring
tour where we will dig into all these
hot topics and give you a proven plan to
build wealth and keep it that's a
promise so each Building Wealth live
event has its own Flair and unique
lineup uh Dave myself Rachel and Jade
will be in Indianapolis February 16th
Dave Ken Dr John and Jade will be in
Austin Texas February 23rd Dave Rachel
myself and Christina will be in Salt
Lake City on April 24th and then we'll
round it out in Anaheim on May 2nd with
Dave Ken Dr John and Christina tickets
start at just 49 bucks or you can get a
four pack of tickets starting at 175.
bring some friends borrow some if you
have to it's going to be amazing
you can get those tickets at
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats today it's been so fun
meeting people in real life in their own
hometowns and seeing the inspiration
happen across the stage it's been
electric Christina I can't wait for you
to join us oh I can't wait and I'm just
so excited because in a world right now
where there's so much fear and so much
negativity for people to see you know
that you can still build wealth that you
can win with money it's just really
exciting hey we're here give us a call
Triple A
825-5225 we'll be right back this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ellis joined Today by George camel and
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five next up
we have Marty calling from Fresno
California hey Marty welcome to the show
hey thank you for having me hey thanks
for calling how can we help
so I have a question
um I have a credit card that has eight
thousand dollars in debt it is a zero
percent interest rate but I do have a
good savings
um that I would be able to pay all of
that off with
my question is would it be wise to use
my savings to pay off that credit card
or should I continue to pay at the zero
percent interest rate pay it off
chaos yeah how much do you have in
savings
I've got 25 000. oh my goodness Marty
what are we doing here you have the
money why are you hanging on to it
you know part of it was because it's on
my husband's account and we were trying
to establish his credit
why so I don't know why he doesn't have
very good credit but why do you why does
he need the credit
um we are wanting to buy our first home
oh there we go okay and and so um yeah
and and we have that
um percentage rate it's it's with
Citibank and it's we I scheduled it to
where I'm paying it off completely on
the last day of the promotion which is a
16-month promotion they will get you
they are snakes do not trust them pay it
off today
at midnight it actually become the next
day and so you're actually going to get
charged back to all of the interest
don't fall for this crap Jesus oh so
here's the deal Marty you actually do
not even need uh credit score in order
to get a house
really and I say that with utmost
confidence because I've done it and
thousands of people have done it
it's called a no score loan through
manual underwriting and so if you have
12 months of rental history you've had a
year of you know cell phone bills and
insurance bills you can use that and
real people will actually look at your
financial situation to approve you for a
mortgage and our friends at Churchill
Mortgage do these all day long and
they'd be happy to help now if you
already have a score because you open
the card that's fine but pay that thing
off and don't look back
do you all have any other debt no okay
God wonderful let's keep it that way
that's it yes oh no we don't want to get
into debt we just thought we were doing
something good you know and getting his
score up but I I knew what to do I just
needed to hear it
that's what we are here for Marty and if
you want more information I did a whole
uh podcast episode on the fine print
about credit scores and about credit
card rewards they're two different
episodes but I think it'll give you some
peace and confidence about not needing
to play the credit score game because
much like you I used to think that way
and I thought well you need the credit
scores to you know what do I need it for
oh to go into debt okay turns out you
can rent apartments you can rent cars
you can even get mortgages without
having that credit score
all right up next we have Adam calling
from Princeton New Jersey hey Adam
welcome to the show
good afternoon thank you so much and
thank you for all you do we really
appreciate it out here everything you're
doing for us of course thanks for
calling how can we help today well my
wife and I are kind of at a Crossroads
actually
um I'm 60 my wife is 68 and we have uh
we have a home in an adult community
it's worth between 250 and 300
000.
um it's paid off uh we have no debt
um where the plan is to you know look
for something less expensive in
Lynchburg so we can still have you know
something left over for what not uh
however in the meantime
um I was let go from my position in
December my wife only has a very small
Social Security uh stipend coming in so
we're we're kind of everything's kind of
been put on pause and we're not sure if
we should continue to actively
uh well we haven't yet but should we
Market the home and you know go forward
or do we stay do we go we're just not
sure what to do we have we have no debt
but we also have no savings so we're
kind of locked into this
precarious position you know we have one
asset and that's all we have really what
was your income before you were let go
uh about 45-ish okay and what's your
wife's Social Security right now
what's her monthly
a little under 600 a month
okay and are you looking for another job
oh absolutely yes absolutely okay so
this is a temporary situation
yes
what were you doing for work
I
barely in customer service okay
is there something where you could get
even temporarily get a part-time job
right now so we can cover the bills for
the next month while we figure out what
the next full-time move is
that's kind of what I'm looking for
right now correct yes yes sir okay then
I I think right now we need to figure
out how we're going to cover next week's
bills
that's a one because I don't think 600
is going to cut it for all of your bills
will it
uh
not really verb kind of Robin from Peter
to pay Paul right now so yeah
yeah you guys have nothing in retirement
and nothing in the bank
correct
um how about your wife can she can she
still work
not at this time no okay
well Adam this is this is all on you
buddy to save the day here and so I'm
gonna it may take swallowing your pride
and going down to whatever local stores
are around and say hey I'm able and
willing to work how soon can I start
and if you can bring in that before so I
know the yeah yeah even if it's 15 bucks
an hour right now and you just work as
much as you can as many hours as you can
while applying for those jobs to get
back to 45 or more but I wouldn't go
listing the house
um as a fire sale quite yet
yeah especially with everything going on
I mean your time and energy right now
needs to really be in finding another
job and figuring out a way to get your
income back up because even if you sell
the house I mean right now you don't
have a mortgage so you're still going to
have to figure out your income somewhere
else and you need to have some sort of
savings to be able to make that move and
to transition to a new city that's a
pretty huge move so right now I would
kind of just take a deep breath take
stock of where you are and then like
George said even if it's just a
temporary few week job where you go to
Target or you know Walmart or something
down the road you know whatever right
just whatever to be able to get above
600 a month and then longer term once we
have stable income we've got to figure
out how are we going to retire what are
we going to do because I can't work
until I'm 75 and so in the next 10 years
how do we make as much money as possible
to start to create that nest egg and
savings so that we can live
um and you might need to downsize
eventually and we're order to create
some income for yourself maybe you know
you downsize to 150 000 home and take
that other 150 from the home sale and
invest that so uh do you have a
financial advisor you're working with
right now
not presently no okay it would be
prudent to connect with a smartvester
pro ramseysolutions.com and figure out a
plan over the next 10 years how are we
going to get Adam and his wife into a
place where they can retire with dignity
and they're not freaking out over the
next month's bills trying to live off of
Social Security well Adam I want to give
you little challenge I want you to of
course go out like we talked about
already and get a job a temporary
situation but I also want you to dream a
little bit I want you to think through
like what is your next ACT career even
if it's for another five to ten years
like this is a temporary fix that we're
gonna do today you're gonna go get that
job but what do you want to do for the
next five to ten years there's all sorts
of people in their 60s and 70s that have
amazing second careers so I want you to
not just live in this space of temporary
solutions but also have that vision for
what you're going to do in the future
and help you with that we're going to
gift you from paycheck to purpose by Ken
Coleman yeah to help you hopefully
develop that dream and then yeah I've
been in that position of having to take
having to take the the only thing that
comes along for quite a while you know
so I haven't really had that room to
like say what do I want to do I haven't
had that choice and yeah well right now
let's do this band yeah let's do both
and let's get something to pay the bills
this month and let's also start dreaming
about what's next hang on the line we'll
get you from paycheck to purpose from
our friend Ken Coleman thanks for the
call Adam we'll be right back this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day is oh taste and see
that the Lord is good blessed is the man
who trusts in him Psalms 34 8 our quote
is it's up to us to choose contentment
and thankfulness now and to stop
imagining that we'll have to have
everything perfect before we'll be happy
Joanna Gaines oh that's good and I like
me some Joanna Gaines but hey it's no
spend month so I will not be looking at
her stuff this month
don't go near a Target Christina right
all right next up we have Tiffany
calling from Virginia hey Tiffany
welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me I'm a
little nervous because he's there with
me hey thanks for calling I'll be so
gentle and so kind
61k currently
um and I'm in bed I'm on baby step
number one
um and I want to pay down my debt like
I'm trying to figure out how do I
balance
um because I have two kids how do I
balance you know the work life and also
making sure I give time to my kids
um like on the weekends or you know
after they come from school so I'm just
trying to figure out how do I find that
wow still working tremendously to pay
down my debt yeah are you doing this on
your own
yes okay and how much debt do you have
um so I have 17 000 in credit cards
and then I have 27 000
um on the current card that I have now
um on the loan and then I co-signed for
my boyfriend's car which is
another thing
I know
is he still in the picture
he is still in the picture yes and he's
making all the payments
yes so he's currently making the
payments on the car and what happens if
he can't make the payments
if he can't make the payments then it
falls all down on me
yeah that's the scary part yeah okay uh
how much is your car worth
um
Kelly Blue Book
and you still owe 27. how are you that
far underwater on it
car previously before this one and then
rolled over the negative equity from
that one and it's so on oh boy
okay
so
your question was really about balancing
the side hustles and family time how old
are the kids
um they are five and nine months
and what are you doing right now as your
full-time job
I'm a housing Housing Locator
okay do you have pretty normal hours
with that
yes
enter are you currently doing the side
hustles
yes okay and those are bringing in extra
or is that 61 total including side
hustles
what are you doing right now
um well right now I'm with the temp
agency
um so I'm doing like concierge work
um you know management roles
um you know when when I'm available and
I just can't seem to find enough time to
be available
yeah who's watching the kids when you're
doing the side hustles right now
um well my boyfriend he gets off pretty
late
um there's no set time for him to get
off work he's a power technician
um so I really don't have anyone to
watch them after after school so I'm
thinking only on weekends but that's the
time I want to take them out and do
things with them and then I feel like
I'll be missing out if I do more time on
the weekends so on the weekends
um are you taking the kids with you is
this work from home or how are you
balancing it
right now I'm not a kind of
um took a pause from the side Hustle but
I want to get back into it with intense
but I I just can't find
how I'm gonna do that was the side
hustle in person
yes
okay that's what I'm I'm thinking that
we probably need to reimagine the side
hustle
um obviously I love that you're wanting
to pay this off and your gazelle intense
but we got to think through how can we
do that and balance being a mom and I'm
thinking ubereats where you can drive
them with you maybe you could get a
customer service job from home maybe
it's a nighttime one where you're
working when the kids are sleeping but I
mean right now the biggest challenge I
think you have is figuring out you know
how can you work and earn income while
also you know keeping the kids with you
does that feel right
um well
I mean I guess it could be okay but just
get just wanting them to be comfortable
and safe
um while I'm out and doing things like
that but I'm suggesting oh that's true
yeah I mean that is a challenge so then
maybe we look at the work at home route
maybe a customer service position
there's a lot of companies that you know
they operate 24 7 and they need people
answering the phone
okay I just want to challenge you to be
creative and think through you know how
you're going to do that because I think
right now the biggest thing you can do
for those babies is get out of debt you
know fight and get through you know be
gazelle intense get through baby step
two but of course you still have to take
care of them so I would really think
that you know how can you safely you
know do an effective job that helps you
make that money and you know move
forward while also watching them and the
purpose of that gazelle intensity
Tiffany is that for a short season you
might not get to take the kids to the
park and do all the things you want to
but the end game is we have so much more
free time and we're not freaked out
financially and we're in a better place
we have Savings in the bank and we don't
have payments to make that puts you in a
very different place and it makes you a
different kind of mom you make decisions
differently and so it may be a really
tough year where you go man I didn't get
to see that nine month old turn into a
one-year nine month old but what they
will see is a mom who worked her tail
off to set them up for a better
financial future
yeah it's a season one for you yeah it's
a season it's not going to be an easy
one but we've seen people do it
countless times and you're going to get
through this and it's so that you can
enjoy full weekends with your kids
someday without the stress and the
anxiety of having that debt looming all
right we've got time for one more call
next up we have Carolyn calling from
Raleigh North Carolina hey Carolyn well
welcome to the show
hi Christina hi George thank you so much
for taking the call yeah of course
so it's decision Tom
um and the decision is whether to repair
an older vehicle or purchase a new to us
car all right are you guys out of debt
yes and you have a fully funded
emergency fund
six months and um so we're on baby steps
four three four and six awesome okay so
what's the car repair gonna cost
okay so minimum is five hundred dollars
maximum is fifteen hundred dollars
um and the vehicle it according to
Kelley Blue Book is in good condition
that means with no mechanical repairs
it's probably only worth three thousand
dollars tops because we have driven this
car of 12 years and it has 223
000 miles
well do you guys have money for a car
outside of the emergency fund have you
been saving up
so we started saving up
um
late last year we have about 6 400
um so we could use that but you know
with the the market the way it is these
days you don't get that great of a
vehicle
um so
we're just not sure what to do do we
take our emergency fund down to three
months and add that that'll bring us
um probably up to about 11 12 000.
that's one option a newer car or do we
make the repairs
what if we split the difference what if
we got a bunch of estimates and went all
right we can get it done for 500 bucks
we're willing to sync that into this car
and then we're going to continue to save
up beyond that 6400 up to nine or ten
that could be a way to go all right
we're going to keep the one we have for
now I don't want you sinking you know
two three grand into this car and then
it's still only worth four grand at the
end of this thing you're not going to
Roi on that which is fine you guys have
gotten a lot of life and mileage out of
this so it's definitely time for the
upgrade I want you to do that regardless
but for now if you're not going to get
the car you really want you guys are in
a great place in baby steps four through
six so I want you to have a better car
Carolyn and you can get there but let's
get a bunch of estimates and see if we
can fix it up for just for now it's a
good word George and I love it that that
233 000 mile car that is right there
all right that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books thanks to
Austin Ben James Zack and Andrew and to
you America for listening we'll be back
soon this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Christina Ellis if you love the
show and want to dive deeper on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]